[Music]
on this thursday night prime minister
trudeau testifies
and denies he influenced the deal with
we charity
we charity received no preferential
treatment not from me
not from anyone else as you don't seem
to understand mr prime minister
the conflict of interest applies to you
the confrontations
the questions and new claims the prime
minister pushed back
on wee's involvement in a student grant
program when he first learned of it
ontario and manitoba unpack plans about
heading back to school this fall
we need to weigh the risks of covet 19
against the harm of school closures the
tricky balance of opening schools and
keeping kids
and the community healthy could the u.s
presidential election be
delayed the idea president trump is
floating as past presidents pay tribute
to a legendary civil rights leader
there are those in power who are doing
their darndest
to discourage people from voting and
blast off nasa's ambitious mission to
mars
rockets into space
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
prime minister justin trudeau under
investigation again for violating ethics
rules
testified in his own defense today and
denied he or anyone in cabinet gave
preferential treatment to the we charity
it has a long history of close ties to
trudeau's family and
finance minister bill morneau's family
and it was given a multi-million dollar
deal to administer a federal student
grant program
there was never any direction by or
attempt to influence
from me or my staff that the public
service
recommend we charity getting young
people to serve
has been a goal of mine well before i
ever got into politics
so i deeply regret how this has unfolded
trudeau and his chief of staff katie
telford testified before the finance
committee to account for a controversy
that is
all their own making and today trudeau
admitted he knew there would be scrutiny
about making a deal with we
and says he pushed back on it abigail
beeman was watching the testimony
abigail
this was the moment the opposition was
waiting for what happened
well donna the prime minister stuck to
the same messaging adding in a few new
details repeating that having we
lead the program was a recommendation
from the non-partisan public service
but he did deliver some news in his
opening statement saying it is
unlikely the student grant program will
happen at all now for weeks the
government has said it's still working
on a way forward
now it seems that's no longer the case
we charity received no preferential
treatment
not from me not from anyone else the
public service
recommended we charity and i did
absolutely nothing to influence
that recommendation may 8 the first time
justin trudeau heard
we was recommended to lead the 900
million dollar student grant program
he testified he and chief of staff katie
telford were briefed
just hours before a cabinet meeting they
had reservations about the speed
and pulled it from the agenda even given
the rapid pace of work during the crisis
this was not the way things were
supposed to go
there are going to be questions because
of the connections with my family on
this
yes in hindsight i should have recused
myself and
perhaps that organi the program would be
delivering for students right across the
country right now
but when he was briefed again may 21
trudeau said he was satisfied by what he
heard from civil servants about due
diligence
the choice was not between providers
it was between going ahead with we
charity to deliver
the program for not going ahead with the
program at all
at that point the prime minister says he
knew about his wife's unpaid work for we
with
expenses repaid and all cleared by the
ethics commissioner he said
and he knew about his brother and
mother's work but not in detail
i did not know how much work either of
them had done with we charity or how
much they'd been paid
conservatives pushed him for the dollar
amounts he said he didn't have any
my money how much has the dollar figure
throughout her life the dollar figure
prime minister various ways and is
how much of the work that she's done and
i'm proud of how much and the ndp
was focused on ethics you give an
impression anyways that
you don't believe that the laws that
define what politicians can and cannot
do
applies to you do you recognize
what you've done here and the damage
that's been done through this
pandemic that as you say has been
extraordinarily difficult and impactful
on canadians
we have remained focused on them but no
clear answers there
either
abigail the prime minister's chief of
staff katie telford testified today too
we
rarely hear from her what did she say
well in her opening remarks katie
telford said she has regrets about
trudeau's lack of recusal she said in
hindsight they could have done
more around the program added another
layer of scrutiny
she also says there were quote a handful
of interactions between the we
organization
and the prime minister's office
including one before the program launch
in early may
but she said in that call a policy
staffer redirected we
to the appropriate department
and abigail this isn't the end of this
of course where do things go from here
well with no major new developments
coming from today's testimony no
more no-esque bombshell like when he
told the committee he wrote we a check
for 41 thousand dollars just prior to
his committee appearance
the government is hoping that we'll let
it focus on other issues the opposition
though will not turn the page anytime
soon and remember there are two
committees studying this as well as
two ethics investigations underway and
calls for others
as well donna all right abigail beeman
in ottawa thank you
one of the key questions is about
influence did the prime minister or the
finance minister influence the decision
to
ask the we organization to administer
this multi-million dollar student grant
program
trudeau testified today as we heard
there was no influence exerted
here's a rough timeline of events on
april 5th the prime minister spoke to
finance minister bill morneau by phone
about ways to help students whose jobs
and volunteer work disappeared because
of the pandemic
the next day the finance department was
tasked with looking into options
on april 7th or 8th the date is in
dispute mourinho's office contacts the
we
organization among other groups to get
their input on potential programs
on april 9th we charity sends an
unsolicited proposal for a youth
entrepreneurship program
to four ministers including mourinho and
trudeau trudeau said today he didn't
know about wee's potential involvement
until may 8
and says he pulled the proposal from
cabinet that day
and asked the public service to go back
and make sure we was the best choice
on may 22nd cabinet including trudeau
and mourinho
approve giving the student grant program
to we
the decision is not made public at that
point on june 25th
it is announced if you're a student and
new grad
we're creating tens of thousands of jobs
for you
trudeau says the nonpartisan public
service made the recommendation
and the government accepted it the we
organization
is the only organization in canada that
has
the scale and the ability to deliver
volunteer opportunities
for young people right across the
country at all levels
of organizations but there are lots of
questions about the prime minister's
close ties to we
and on july 3 the agreement with we is
polled
the federal ethics commissioner launches
an investigation into the prime
minister's role in awarding it
on july 8 the prime minister
acknowledges he did not recuse himself
from the cabinet meeting in may
the next day it's reported trudeau's
wife mother and brother were paid a
total of almost three hundred thousand
dollars in fees to appear at we events
on july 13th trudeau apologizes for
staying in that cabinet meeting
when the decision was made to go with we
i made a mistake
and not recusing myself immediately from
the discussions
given our family's history and i'm
sincerely
sorry the finance minister who also has
close ties to we
has also apologized and repaid money for
family trips
taken with the charity
the summer job grant program was
supposed to help students who were
wondering what the next
months will hold for them because of the
pandemic the future is still
uncertain and today ontario and manitoba
laid out plans for returning to school
in september
both provinces will be getting students
back into the classroom
and ontario is the first province to
mandate masks for some grades
mike delay explains what parents of
millions of kids have been waiting for
with precise physical distancing and
mandatory masks in place
ontario premier doug ford announced a
path forward for students
my friends we're going to get our kids
back to school in a way
that looks and feels as much as it used
to the plan calls for elementary school
students to remain in the same cohort or
class
while having staggered recesses and
lunch breaks secondary students mostly
in larger schools
will go to an adapted model with a
maximum of 15 students in class
on alternate days and all students from
grades 4 through 12
will be required to wear a mask parents
can opt out of sending their child to
class
if they wish little kids aren't actually
not that contagious
um they'll get it from their parents but
they won't give it to their parents so i
think with littler with younger kids
i'm not really that concerned about big
outbreaks
ontario was the first province to cancel
classes in mid-march after the pandemic
hit
opting for a distance learning program
that saw students in front of their
teachers
for as little as an hour a week the
model was
as good as we could make it when we did
the at home and distance learning
however i do think we need to be in
front of our students
other provinces have announced similar
restart plans although all have their
own terminology and methods
for keeping students physically distant
manitoba's plan
is more relaxed than ontario's giving
the students the option of remote
learning
and if that doesn't work they'll adapt
it's the reality
of dealing with a pandemic that it would
be wrong for
for me to tell you that we know
exactly how things are going to go in
september october
teachers and school nurses will
certainly be extra vigilant
but it all starts with parents like
bianca smalley who hopes other parents
do as she plans to
and keeps their kids home if they're
sick so like
people just you know have to choose
between sending your kid in with
you know the sniffles or losing
a day's pay and losing you know your
ability to feed your family
the bottom line is it has to work the
alternative
is more home schooling mike drolit
global news toronto
there's a sobering snapshot of the state
of the american economy tonight
the pandemic has triggered the sharpest
economic contraction in modern american
history
the gdp the broadest measure of economic
activity shrank by 32.9 percent in the
second quarter
in the spring many u.s businesses
screeched to a halt
and the u.s is now in its first
recession in 11 years
that is not good news for president
donald trump who likes to champion
economic growth today he did something
his critics feared he might try
donald trump floated the idea of
delaying november's presidential
election
he doesn't actually have the power to do
that but he raised it in a tweet and
also claimed
mail-in voting as an alternative to
voting in person
is too risky and could lead to fraud
jackson proskow explains what could be
behind
the wild idea down double digits in the
polls and with his re-election at risk
president donald trump floated an idea
that could upend democracy
delay november's election does president
trump have the ability to delay the
election
president trump does not have the
ability to delay
the election no president has the
ability to delay
an election in a tweet trump wondered if
there was some way to delay the election
until people can properly securely and
safely vote
implying it's too risky during the
pandemic
baselessly suggesting that mail-in
ballots as an alternative to in-person
voting
will lead to widespread voter fraud do i
want to see a day change
no but i don't want to see a crooked
election this election will be the most
rigged election in history
no matter what this country has been
through war
famine the great depression there's
never been
a delay in federal elections four years
ago trump falsely claimed in-person
voter fraud caused him to lose the
popular vote
now he's targeting vote by mail recently
suggesting he may not accept the outcome
of the election
can you give a direct answer you will
accept the election
look you i have to see in a stirring
rebuke
former president barack obama addressed
trump without naming him
during his eulogy to civil rights icon
john lewis
even as we sit here there are those in
power
who are doing their darndest
to discourage people from voting even
undermining the postal service
in the run-up to an election
that's going to be dependent on mail-in
ballots so people don't get sick
as for the question at hand only
congress could change the date of the
election and even trump's republican
allies on capitol hill
have said they're not interested in
doing that even if they did
the constitution says the president's
term ends on january 20th
so donna at this point all trump can do
is disrupt faith in the process
but not the process itself
jackson in washington thanks former u.s
republican presidential candidate herman
cain
has died from complications of covid 19.
he was hospitalized less than two weeks
after attending president trump's
campaign rally in tulsa oklahoma
in june many attendees including kane
did not wear masks
and there was a surge in kovid 19 cases
in tulsa
after the event the legacy of a civil
rights legend coming up mourners
including past presidents pay tribute to
john lewis
american civil rights leader john lewis
was remembered today as a man who often
got into what he called
good trouble necessary trouble in the
fight for equality
his funeral took place in atlanta which
he represented in congress for more than
three decades
he was the first of the freedom riders
the youngest speaker on the march on
washington
leader of the march from selma to
montgomery and the man known
as the conscience of congress you
may seek the funeral drew hundreds of
mourners to ebenezer baptist church
the sanctuary of reverend dr martin
luther king jr
a twelve-year-old boy a friend of lewis
read
from one of his favorite poems invictus
i'm the master of my fate
i'm the captain of my soul three former
presidents were among the mourners
george w bush barack obama and bill
clinton
he was here on a mission that was bigger
than
personal ambition obama called lewis one
of his heroes
and in his eulogy drew parallels between
the battles lewis took part in during
the civil rights movement
and protests for racial justice
happening across america
now we see it outside our windows in big
cities
and rural towns in men
and women young and old
straight americans and lgbtq americans
blacks who long for equal treatment and
whites who can no longer accept freedom
for themselves while
witnessing the subjugation of their
fellow americans
just weeks before his death lewis
visited the black lives matter plaza in
washington
and witnessed how police brutality has
ignited
national outrage in a final essay
written before he died and published in
the new york times today
lewis writes though i am gone i urge you
to answer the highest calling of your
heart
and stand up for what you truly believe
[Music]
a call to action from a towering figure
in the civil rights movement
lewis was 80 years old
[Music]
we're back in a moment
you're watching global national
[Music]
hong kong plans to open its newest field
hospital within the next three days
there are now more than 3 100 known
cases of covid19 in hong kong
the converted exhibition center will
hold up to 2 000 beds
the chinese government is helping to
build the hospital though hong kong
officials say beijing
won't be involved with medical staff and
australia is imposing some strict
new rules after a record spike in
infections
starting on sunday face masks will be
mandatory in the state of victoria
many of the 723 new infections reported
today were in the state capital
melbourne that's despite the city being
in the middle of a six-week lockdown
the premier victoria has warned
melbourne may be locked down for even
longer if the infection rate doesn't
begin
to drop brazil's president jair
bolsonaro
who often has played down the pandemic
is recovering from covid19 and now his
wife
is infected officials confirmed today
first lady michelle bolsonaro tested
positive for covid19 and in a statement
they say she's in good health
and will follow necessary precautions
brazil's science minister has also
tested positive
he's the fifth minister in bolsonaro's
government to be infected
next new hopes for new answers nasa's
latest mission to mars
it's being called the most sophisticated
mars mission in history
perseverance just blasted off and is the
latest robotic rover
designed to search for evidence of life
on the red planet
as eric sorenson reports the multi-year
mission will not only look for signs of
microbial life
it will set the stage to bring back
samples of mars
to earth a shiny new martian rover
perseverance is the precious cargo
inside this atlas rocket
zero release it's a multi-year
multi-billion dollar journey to discover
with certainty
whether there has ever been life on mars
perseverance will land here in jezreel
crater
because three and a half billion years
ago jezreel was a lake
fed by a river surrounded by an
atmosphere that may have supported life
i would imagine you know everything from
that point forward is going to be
okay what other life is out there how do
we get to it how do we study it how do
we understand it
it'll be it'll be absolutely the biggest
discovery i think in history
today mars is a dusty forbidden
landscape perseverance will roam
and survey and deploy the first
helicopter ever flown on a different
planet
so this will actually be a very much a
wright brothers moment
except on another planet with
perseverance on route
july has become rush hour to mars last
week
china launched chianwen won to orbit and
deploy a rover on the martian surface
a few days before that the united arab
emirates sent a spacecraft called hope
to study the atmosphere of mars a first
for the arab
world in space the space exploration
towards mars uae now is as a member of
the
club the three missions to mars hope
chanwin won and now perseverance have
all left earth now
because the window of opportunity only
comes every 26 months
the goal is to have the three spacecraft
intersect with the martian orbit when
the red planet is relatively nearby
the trek will still cover more than 560
million kilometers
all three will arrive at their
destination in february of 2021
seven months from now perseverance will
be the first in a series of missions not
just to explore but to gather pieces of
mars and bring them back to earth
it will drill some 30 rock cores to be
sealed in cigar-shaped tubes
future missions will collect the samples
and return them to earth in 2031.
canadian team member chris hurd can't
wait if everything goes well we'll have
really intriguing evidence
potentially for in the form of organic
molecules detected
or or even certain structures in the
rock that could be indicative
that life was there but to have that
definitive proof we need to bring those
samples back and see them in the lab
this is not just another space flight it
may settle the age-old question
are we alone in the universe eric
sorensen global news
toronto and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's here canada is elk island
national park in alberta it plays a big
part in the conservation of the plains
bison
send us your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
and thanks for watching hope to see you
here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you